MIT's origami club which we call OrigaMIT, is a student
run organization where folders can come from the
surrounding area and the entire MIT community is welcome
to come and just learn to fold something new or try
something they've already done before; come in and show
something off. I first saw origami in fourth grade and from
then on I was just infatuated with it and I always wanted to
learn how to transform paper into cool objects. When I
came to MIT I found out there was this club for it, and it
was amazing coming to it and learning everyones advanced
skill levels and things like that.
So origami is basically ancient Japanese art of paper
folding. Ori stands for folding, and gami the word it comes
from means paper. It's been practiced for hundreds of
years and keeps getting more advanced and more
geometrically complicated.
I made a hercules beetle that was so complicated it has
six legs body pinchers and lots of things and one sheet of
paper.
A lot of young kids do come into our club and all of them
have varying degrees of experience. Some of them are
beginners, just learning how to fold cranes and other simple
models, but some of them are really ambitious and they
in to try and learn how to design their own origami.
I've been doing origami since I was five.
We try to help those who are still learning how to fold
and those who are interested in origami design we talk to
them a bit and really encourage them.
A lot of people are intimidated by OrigaMIT. They think that
because we're all MIT students that everything is super
advanced and we use all this math to fold stuff, when really
anyone can do it.
I think its because MIT students like to challenge
themselves. Anything that someone else has done before
they feel like they can do it too.
That was my first attempt but I couldn't get it together so I
made a larger one and then went back and put that one
together, once I understood how everything went together.
Normally when you give people diagrams when they get to
a part that they need help with they'll ask for help, but MIT
students they like to just keep at it, by themselves, just keep
working on it. It's like, "OK I can get this, I can do this
myself." I highly encourage anyone, even if you've never
folded before to just stop by because you might find out
how much you love it and keep coming back.